sara is with us in Atlanta Georgia hi
Sara how are you hi Dave I'm good how
are you
better than I deserve what's up it's so
exciting to talk to you you too
thank you um okay so basically um I have
been married for 16 years I am a
stay-at-home mom to our children and we
my husband I have taken a Financial
Peace University together and we are on
track on our monthly budget we're on
step two right now we have two sources
of debt the first we have is a car loan
and that is almost paid off it will be
paid off in five months
and we have my student loan which is
twenty six thousand dollars and we're
chipping away at that next after the car
my question to you is that my husband
has an opportunity to get some side work
coming in that will generate um some
money he it is good except for instead
of putting the money into the student
loans he's he's a little bit bitter with
the student loan because it's my student
loan and I've tried to explain him that
it's actually our debt because we're
married but he has suggested that and we
buy things with with this money instead
of debts no buying it and and because he
doesn't feel responsible for your
student loan yes yes and he suggested
that um I pay for it when I get an
inheritance okay um well I could give
you two answers and I'll try to give you
both of them the first one is the smart
I like answer the next time he brings
that up you should give him a bill for
$56,000 for the care and feeding of his
children and the meals that you cook and
the cleaning that you do and that's an
annual bill by the way mm-hmm you could
just submit an invoice to him
mmm-hmm what a butt yeah
what about really I mean honestly I mean
he's he's laying in the bed with the flu
and by god he wants chicken soup from
you what happened to the for richer for
poorer in sickness and health unto thee
all my worldly goods I pledge I'll take
a bullet for you you're my spouse but I
won't pay your student loan while you're
a full-time mom taking care of my kids
okay that's the smart aleck answer
mm-hmm all right the the real answer
that's just a but just to give you a
little validity so some of the crap
inside your that you are feeling okay
the real answer is you need to sit down
with your pastor you guys need marriage
counseling okay that's real answer okay
smart aleck answer is not gonna work
right I'm just stirring up trouble and I
don't want to stir up trouble actually
when I help you but you know that's
that's what you were feeling inside if
you've got a backbone weren't you yes
okay so I got to tell you I can see
Sharon Ramsey's face turn inside out if
I tried that crap she would no longer be
a pretty woman if I said face it would
look like one of those metamorphoses on
a monster movie and mine did it does
yeah it just wouldn't work
it just wouldn't fly it cause it's just
wrong it's just wrong on so many levels
so now we need to work together and
clean up our messes together we're a
family we fight debt together we fight
cancer together we raise kids together
we fix broken cars together we work
together to run our lives
that's what being married is all about
okay we're there for each other and that
that's what this is so sorry but you
guys probably do need to do that now
listen and also since I since I was so
hard on him we'll be there September
24th and I'm going to give you two free
tickets to the smart money event since
financial peace somehow didn't do it
maybe Chris Hogan and me there live will
help oh my goodness I'm so excited okay
you guys come to that but in the
meantime in all seriousness all joking
and
snarkiness aside you guys probably do
need to sit down with and I'm not saying
you're heading for a divorce but this is
a big breakdown in the value system of
your marriage and so it your marriage at
least needs a tune-up it's running rough
yeah and there's no harm in that except
you don't deal with it if you don't deal
with it it just gets worse so sit down
with a pastor or a good marriage
counselor and unpack some of this and
get some advice on you guys working
together for shared goals the nobility
of working together all these years is
what causes marriage to be wonderful
it's what makes us endure the other
parts oh my goodness
you